this week we're talking about
supercomputers magic buttons and the
smartest hundred dollars you ever made
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news this
year alone job listings requiring
goo-goo cloud skills shot up by 65% and
our professional cloud architect
certification was named the top paying
IT certification as if you needed any
more encouragement we are rolling out
the cloud certification challenge on
your certificate within 12 weeks of
signing up for the challenge and we will
give you $100 in Google store credit to
make it even easier you'll get free
access to courses on quick labs and
Coursera as well as tips on taking the
exam itself well what are you waiting
for
our ability to generate data is starting
to outpace our capacity to process it
but it won't for long
thanks to X's scaler an in cloud file
system that Google recently developed in
partnership with ddn this is big news if
you're running a high-performance
computing application or planning to
build anything AI intensive in the
future read the post to learn more about
the unique benefits of using X a scalar
jointly with the Google cloud platform
and see which industries stand to gain
the most then try it out this could
reason to love events or systems but we
notice there weren't any off-the-shelf
solutions for getting one up and running
so we built one this guide walks you
through the why and the how of bringing
an event source system into being and
how to tackle some key challenges like
keeping messages in order creating a
schema registry and triggering workloads
based on published events check it out
if you regularly work with sensitive
data you know how important data loss
prevention tools are adding the ability
to access those tools seamlessly from
within the GCP services like bigquery
just makes sense
introducing the scan with DLP button by
using scan with
dlb you'll be able to detect common
sensitive data types create triggers for
automatic DLP scan scheduling publish
reports for further analysis and even
obfuscate sensitive data and all without
leaving your database if you value data
protection and compliance and you love
pressing buttons for a worthy cause
tryouts can with DLP today if you want
to read more about these announcements
or see a full list check out the link
have any thoughts or ideas leave us a
comment or tweet us we'll see you in the
cloud
you